what happened before
this all originated
what's outside the universe
divided by zero
okay so it's not
it's not relevant not understandable
is it useful to even ask the question no
just
because it's so hard no it's not hard
it's just not a question
if i can't do an experiment or even
think of experiment the question doesn't
exist
well no you can't think of a lot of
experiments no offense
what i mean is why your causality graph
is like this is what we've been talking
about
it's like um
there is limits to your ability
to construct experiments i agree but i'm
i'm i was trying to be facetious and i'm
trying to make a point so i think that
if you if there is a
causal bottleneck
through which information can't
propagate in principle
then it's very hard
to ask to think of an experiment even in
principle even one that's beyond my my
mediocre
intellect right which is fine i'm happy
to accept that but this is one of the
things i actually do think there was
something before the big bang because
i'm i would say that i think the big
bang just couldn't occur and create time
time created the big bang
but uh there was time before the big
bang yeah there there's no space for
those times yeah
yeah
but i mean i'm just making that stuff up
just to make all the physicists happy
but i think it's
that would you think that would make
them happy because they would be quite
upset actually and why would they be
upset because they would say that like
time can't exist before
yeah i mean this goes back to an
argument that you might not want to do
have the argument here i i was talking
to sarah earlier today about an argument
we had about time a long time ago
time in time and what i would it's like
i think there is this thing called time
or state creation the universe is
creating states and it's outside of
space
but they create space so what i mean is
you can imagine there are states being
created all the time and there is this
thing called time
time is a clock which you can use to
measure when things happen but that
doesn't mean because you can't measure
something that states aren't being
created
and so you might locally refer to
the big bang and the bing bang occurred
at some point
in when those states were there
probably there had to be enough states
for the big bang to occur
um and then
but i i i think that there is something
wrong with our conception of how the
universe was created in the big bang um
because we don't really get time um
because again you know i don't want to
become boring and sound like a broken
record but but um
time is a real thing and until
i can really explain that more elegantly
i'm just going to get into more trouble
we're going to talk about time because
time is useful measuring device for
experiments but also time is an idea all
that okay but let me first ask sarah is
like what what do you think
is it a useful question to ask what
happened
before the big bang is a useful question
ask what's outside
the universe
so i would think about it as the big
bang is an event that we reconstructed
as probably happening in the past of our
universe based on current observational
data and so the way i like to think
about it is
we exist locally
in something called the universe
um so and and going back to like the
physics of existence we exist locally in
the space of all things that could exist
and we can infer certain properties of
the structure of where we exist locally
and one of the properties that we've
inferred in the past is that there is
a
a thing we call the big bang there's
some signatures of our local environment
that indicate that there was a very
um low information
uh
event that started our universe i think
that's actually just an artifact of
the structure of the assembly space that
when you
when you
start losing all the memory in the
objects it it looks like what we call a
big bang um so i think it makes sense to
talk about where you are locally
i think it makes sense to talk about
counter factual possibilities what could
exist outside the universe in the sense
that they become part of our reasoning
and therefore part of our causal chain
of things that we can do
so like the multiverse in my mind exists
but it doesn't exist as a multiverse of
possible universes it exists as an idea
in our minds that allows us to reason
about how physics works and then to do
physics differently because we reason
about it that way
um so i always like to re-center it on
things exist but they don't always exist
like we think they exist
so when we're thinking about things
outside the universe they absolutely
exist because we're thinking about them
but they don't look like
they don't look like the projections in
our minds they're something else
something you said just gave an idea to
go back to your question
if
there was core i mean some if something
caused the big bang if there was some
memory or some artifact of that then of
course it's to answer your question it's
worth going back to that because it that
would imply there is something beyond
that barrier that filter yeah and that's
what you were saying i guess right
i'm agnostic to what exists outside the
universe i just don't think that like i
think the most interesting things for us
to be doing are finding explanations
that allow
us to do more like like that optimism so
i tend to draw the boundary on questions
i ask as being scientific ones because i
find
that that's where the most creative
potential is to impact the future
trajectory of what we're doing on this
planet the interesting thing about the
big bang is basically from our
current perspective of what we're able
to detect
it's the time when things were forgotten
yes
it's the time the reset
from our limited perspective and so the
question is is it useful to ever
study the thing that was forgotten
um or should we focus just on the on the
memories that are still there well the
point i was trying to make of the
experiment is i was trying to say both
things and i think perhaps yes from the
pot following point of view if you could
then imagine what was forgotten
and then work forwards you will have
different consequences so then it
becomes testable so i'm as long as we
can find tests and it's definitely worth
thinking about what i don't like is when
physicists say what happened before the
big bang and before before before
without giving me any credible
um conjecture about what we would
what how would we know the difference
but the way you've framed it is quite
nice i like that it's like a what
what have we forgotten
you